this is a production of Cornell
University
well i'm sure this seminar is
of a departure from what you're used to
it's not going to be very heavy on
research and data but it's more sort of
letting you know about Who I am some of
the things I've been doing I don't know
if Justine is here or not there she is i
wanted to thank justine because she very
nicely pointed out that this was the
first seminar that has the word
disappointments and lies in the title of
course but as Neil said I am from New
Jersey and I think the best thing you
can say about New Jersey is that it's a
wonderful place to be from but you know
it's sorry I didn't I didn't come from a
farm background at all I grew up in the
suburbs of New Jersey and I still have
family there which I have to go back and
visit and fight the traffic on so before
I get started about sort of some of the
things i do i just wanted to say thanks
to a few people and some of you here
will recognize the the gentleman in the
upper left hand part of the screen there
was bob becker and bob becker was on the
faculty at geneva for a number of years
that's who i replaced he was just a
wonderful person one hundred percent
extension unfortunately i only got to
learn from him for a couple of years
because because he passed away soon
after I arrived a couple of years later
but Bob certainly was a wonderful mentor
for me you know also at the time when I
was hired you price was my chair and
again I couldn't have a better chair
person to to learn from any price and
you know one of the reasons I think I've
had some success in my career is because
when I came here I inherited a wonderful
research support specialist technician
in Jim ballasting and it's jim has been
at Cornell for nearly 30 years has been
running the lot of the the vegetable
trials the processing vegetable trials
for a number of years
you know his leadership really allows me
to get more into the teaching to get
more into the extension that I wouldn't
be able to do if I had to stay back in
Geneva so again you know I just want to
give those acknowledgments upfront so
for those of you that are not familiar
with the vegetable industry in New York
State we are surprisingly large
vegetable producers usually about fifth
in the nation in terms of fresh market
and these are the major crops there's
about eight to ten what I'll call major
crops worth anywhere from maybe thirty
to a hundred million dollars on a given
year we r divided most of it about
ninety percent of the value of the
industry is based in the fresh market
side but we also still grow quite a few
processing crops and you can see when
I'm talking processing vegetables we're
talking sweet corn and snap beans peas
crowd cabbage carrots and beets some of
those you know some of the acreage have
gone down on those I know some people
will say that every time an old person
dies in Florida they lose one more
person that was eating crap cabbage but
hopefully we've got some new things and
new products that are coming out and
crowd that are somewhat exciting and
then here's where we rank as a state
provides guy said fresh market wise know
for a lot of people when they think of
New York they don't think of agriculture
but certainly we are number five in
terms of fresh market acres and and our
value is right up there and processing
where we're ranked lower but still doing
pretty good I don't have newer numbers
from the 2012 AG census apparently
because of the shutdown in the federal
government last fall we're still waiting
to get the 2012 results but what I do
have from 2002 the 2007 is that we've
seen an increase the number of farms in
New York that are actually growing
vegetables some of those are existing
farms where they've added vegetables
they might have been growing some other
things and we also have a lot of small
farmers just getting started with new
folks that are coming out and trying to
get going in that business don't you
want the
acreage or an entity to be considered a
farm now the question was what the
minimum entity is to be considered a
Pharma I believe it has to do with how
much they earn from it and that I don't
know offhand okay and our farms you know
they run from a couple of acres of very
diversified crops to to several thousand
acres of processing vegetables so we
certainly run a wide range of different
groups here now this is just a trend
that we've seen in vegetable acre since
1990 and you can see it's been pretty
steady the Green Line is for processing
crops and the red line is for fresh
market crops you know what I'd like you
to look at first is what happened here
and you can see there was a huge spike
in production processing acres at that
at that time now a lot of people would
say that was because seneca foods one of
our processors worked out an arrangement
with green giant to grow a lot of what
they were packing for Green Giant right
here in New York State I prefer to think
that there was another reason that is
when I was hired so I suppose maybe the
deal with Seneca foods might have
something to do with that as well and
although I could embarrass some other
entomologist pathologist and
horticulturalist about when they were
hired and what might be happening with
the trends here I won't i won't do that
but they do know who they are out there
I know as I was sitting down and
thinking about all the issues that
vegetable growers face and these are
issues I think that it's the fruit
growers fuel crop growers the ornamental
growers they all face these sort of same
type of things probably if you ask them
the number one problem they have concern
they have is labor where is the labor
going to come from all of these crops
with the exception of processing
vegetables require a lot of hand labor
so where is that coming from the cost of
doing business in New York the
competition how are they going to market
you'll insects and diseases we still
have the same ones that have been
bothering us for generations and we have
new ones constantly coming in we control
which I like to separate out from the
insects and diseases because very often
especially for beginning farmers weeds
is what kills them they never expect the
weeds to do it they worry about insects
they worry about diseases they don't
have a plan in place for weeds the
availability of pesticides in New York
State we are usually a couple of years
behind
of our neighboring states in terms of
the pesticides that are going to be
available and labeled for the growers
the food safety issues we have a
changing climate we're certainly seeing
more extremes in the climate and growers
are aware of that we're seeing longer
seasons that can be good to we're seeing
crops that we couldn't grow here that
you can grow here as well we have the
issue of the large farm source the
smaller forms yeah a lot of the same
problems but how are they going to react
to those problems what are they going to
do to try to solve those problems might
be very different based on the scale we
have experienced farmers that have been
in business with their families for
generations and we have farmers that are
just getting started and then finally I
want to talk about this more at the end
the loss of faculty and with the loss of
faculty the loss of the research that
they were doing so again this is my
position ten percent teaching twenty
percent research seventy percent
extension that was as a last Monday
that's going to change because
apparently I will get some
administration in there as well and if
you look at this one picture that is me
pipe heading something out of a out of a
bottle and I'd love to tell you that
it's a nice safe maybe a surfactant or
something that I was using but this is
the 1980s and this was a time when you
know things were done a little
recklessly and that was probably a very
bed and sect aside for potatoes that I
was putting out at that time it's
probably why my hair turned gray so
prematurely because of that but again I
got a chance to work at the experiment
station at Rutgers and really had a good
time down there in terms of teaching
teach three different classes I teach
the [ __ ] 3500 that's vegetable
production class that I teach with Robyn
Belinda came out of the old class that
varela Brock used to teach new class I
just started this year it's just a one
credit which was a lot of fun which is
organic vegetable gardening and then
since 2000 I've been teaching a
three-week section of the hort 14 that
number is not right is it for what it
should be 45 for whatever it's the plant
nutrition class and I teach a three-week
section and vegetables in that as well
the teaching is a lot of fun one thing I
love about teaching is with the students
they ask you questions that always get
you thinking and having to do a little
bit more research because you have
answer the question the next time you
see them and in our vegetable production
class you know I really have to thank
the Steve McKay and his crew over at R
evil because they take a Saturday
morning we take the class out they get
to see everything from the Tao how a
field is prepared all the way to putting
down plastic and planting into that
plastic mulch and how trickle irrigation
works and not only do they get to see
that but they get to do that they're
driving the tractors they're working the
equipment and so far we haven't lost
anybody and haven't had any major
accidents but it's just been a wonderful
experience we have field trips that we
go on we go out and see some of the
processing vegetables being harvested we
visit a processing plant we go to some
smaller fresh market operations and see
what they've got and if you look up here
in the upper right-hand corner that's
actually a corn harvester and about half
the class is actually up on the corn
harvester going through the field
watching that harvest take place in
terms of advising I don't have any
undergraduates that I do advise I never
have had any I have been lucky enough to
have three students that went through
the summer internship program that
Cornell Cooperative Extension offers and
that's a wonderful program if you
haven't been able to participate in it
it's really good at what it does is it
matches an undergraduate student with
either a county or regional based person
around the state and you as a faculty
and you design a project that that
person will work on and then report on
it's also a wonderful way to try to
identify potential graduate students
because my first one was Sarah you look
that I had back in 2008 and once i
worked with sarah for that summer that
was somebody i watched for the next few
years so i could grab her as a graduate
student who of course we did have her as
she just finished up just last year
working on pumpkins and we had eight
miles yeah i'm sure many of you are a
number that was doing a project and
peppers and cover cropping looking at
the research I just sort of listed the
crops that I work on and sort of the
area's soil fertility stand
establishment have ICM or integrated
crop management because a lot of the
work that I do is working cooperatively
with the entomologist at the plant
pathologists or weed scientists to try
to come up with sort of a horticultural
aspect to the problem that we're looking
at to see if there's a cultural method
that yields going to be different than
what they may
have and I think some of the best and
most enjoyable things I've done is the
cooperative work that I that I've been
participating in over the past 20 years
I like to going to point this one out as
an example that I think is just a really
good example of cooperation you know I
think land-grant colleges universities
are often blamed as being very slow to
react to things here is a problem that
first came up growers came to us in the
fall of two thousand and one they had a
problem there was a new a fit that was
out that the Asian soybean aphid came in
from probably Canada was first reported
in New York in 2001 and since then we've
been with us every year well one more a
fad you know we're used to a fits the
problem with that was that it was
carrying cucumber mosaic virus and
cucumber mosaic virus was causing huge
yield losses and snap beans processing
snap beans and fresh market snap beans
so what were we going to do to try to
combat this well this is where again
being able to call on colleagues that
have expertise in so many different
areas can really be helpful again mark
Fuchs the biologist up in Geneva who you
know whenever you bring him a sample of
anything that looks like it potentially
has virus he gets excited about it he
always tells you it's not virus and
blames robin a herbicide or something is
we like to do but it's great to have him
there and be able to take any samples
that we've got so we've got him there to
really anchor everything you know the
long-term solution of course is breeding
Phil Griffiths has a very active
snapping breeding program breeding takes
time but he's got some wonderful
materials that are coming out into the
pipeline now that are resulting in
varieties that truly resistant to
cucumber mosaic virus as well as some
other viruses Brian Nault the
entomologist he was looking at the
soybean aphid how is it spreading is
there an insecticide that could be used
other seed treatments that could be used
what's happening where is it coming from
so working out all of those things
question about was the seed born well we
have al Taylor seed science and he
helped us with that and some of the
early work on some of the variety
establishment Julie kickert who's not on
faculty but as an Extension educator
working at the cornell vegetable program
working with in western New York with
processors who's that liaison between
the faculty and the work that's going on
here and with the industry and actually
helping to do some of the field trials
as well and then finally in my program
what we did was we looked at all the
existing varieties it's going to take a
while to breathe new ones what existing
varieties that are out there that could
actually make a difference in terms of
the grower being able to plant this year
and the year after in the year after and
get by until we have truly resistant
varieties so and we work together we had
funding from the five formed by a bill
of the Institute from AG and markets you
know put these trials out and at the in
the end at least in my part of the
program we found about half a dozen
varieties that were actually quite
tolerant to this virus that they could
plant and even in a year where you had
soybean aphids at very high levels and
hi virus though as you were still able
to get a pretty good yield from that
okay and again and we're constantly
checking for the new varieties and some
of this leads to other research because
what we found was that the varieties
that seemed to be more tolerant to the
disease actually we need to look at the
fertility levels because they're
responding to more nitrogen more than
what we traditionally have done with
beans and that's something we've got to
look at for for next year again I just
throw that as a really good example of
you know when we come together we work
together we can really get some good
solutions here and the pumpkin work that
we did you know traditionally for many
years pumpkins were probably the last
crop that a grower seated went back at
the end of the year harvested whatever
he had and that was it things start to
change by the early 1990s Americans are
spending a lot of money on Halloween
buying a lot of pumpkins for
jack-o'-lantern said yes probably ninety
nine point five percent of all the
pumpkins that are grown in this in this
state in this country outside of
Illinois with a growing for processing
guard grown just for ornamental sales
okay so the typical thing they do grower
goes out plants a seed over seeds it may
go back and thin or just leave it alone
and then he harvest question comes up as
the seed gets more expensive the growers
come to us and say what about using
transplants yeah there are other methods
that we could use so we don't have to
you know the seeds expensive as we're
getting new varieties that are coming
out that are very resistant tolerant to
diseases like powdery mildew and what
about using some other methods well we
fooled around with it I did a lot of
work in the 1990s we're working with
Dale rigs that some of you might
remember and we were looking at spacing
of pumpkins trying to get the
ideal spacing for the yield that you
want if you're a grower that's selling
pumpkins by number so you want a lot of
fruit but they could be smaller put the
pumpkins more closely together get more
higher plant population if you're
growing by size you want the pumpkins
other bigger size space them out more
fewer plants per acre would give you a
larger size pumpkin ok so again you know
pumpkins are a great crop to work with
not only there there one that you don't
need to be harvesting every couple of
days like you do with tomatoes and
peppers you go out there at the end of
the year you pick up everything in Syria
wait you've got your your yield data and
plus when you have a field of two acres
of pumpkins you're very popular in the
fall a lot of people are always going to
be happy that you've got some pumpkins
and you can easily get rid of those when
we've been doing trials with beets
sometimes people are not that happy
about getting all the extra beats that
we have so what I've got here what Sarah
did in her work was she looked at the
traditional planting direct seeding into
bare ground and that's that red bar over
there this is the yield per plot so this
isn't on a per acre or a hectares
kilograms per plot and then the green
blue and yellow those are the different
transplant sizes she was using okay so
the green was a smaller transplant you
get more plants into the greenhouse with
those up to the yellow which was a
larger transplant and again so it's
going to take up more room be a more
expensive transplant grow them for about
three weeks doesn't have to be in the
greenhouse very long and she planted
those right into the bare ground and
what we saw was thirty forty percent
even better increase in yield that we
had out there with the pumpkins what we
were doing that so the growers were also
asking what about you know if you if
you're doing transplants what about
putting the transplants right into
plastic mulch instead of bare ground so
again one of the trials that she did
that same year was again using direct
seeded into plastic molds just making
hole in the plastic mulch and planting
along with the transplant size and you
can see that again the yields were
increased with all those compared to
what was the traditional planting of
direct seeding into bare soil and what
we came away with here is that a grower
has two options the grower could if they
want to go with bare soil and not use
plastic mulch they could do that but
they're going to be a real advantage in
terms of the yields they use a
transplant three-week-old transplant
the other advantage if they didn't want
to go that way they could use plastic
mulch and they could direct seed it what
happens when you direct seed into
plastic mulch it's warm the environment
is perfect you get germination very
quickly and by doing either going into
plastic or using transplants what can
happen is that you can plant later
instead of pumpkins that need to be
probably planted around the fifth or
tenth of june you can't plan probably
almost as late as the first of july so
now you're talking about being able to
get maybe two crops in that field in the
same season so again it's a real
advantage that we have it does cost more
and sarah ran the numbers with brad
Ricker and you know we found that with
yield increase of probably 20 25 percent
you easily would pay for the plastic
mulch or the transplant cost that you'd
have okay now I know probably many of us
have bad things to say about
entomologists but I do want to say that
entomologists when you find a good one
and we and we certainly have some good
ones here at Cornell and just peterson
was a postdoc and she was working with
Brian Nault and Brian's been doing a lot
of work looking at pollination issues
and pumpkins and i'm sure most of you
realize this but pumpkins are manisha so
they've got mail and they've got female
flowers and of course you need the bees
to go in and move that Colin fascinating
plants because what you see is that
there's usually you know 20 to 30 male
flowers for every female flower unlike
the human population where every male is
valued in pumpkins not so much and
there's a lot of environmental effects
that can have an impact on the number of
female flowers first male flowers and
when you're doing this kind of work you
have to go out there early in the
morning five o'clock in the morning when
the flowers are just beginning to open
and start to do this work so and there's
a lot more to this but I just wanted to
boil this now because this is something
that really changes the way people have
traditionally been augmenting their
fields with bees do you need to put
hives out there certainly we're having a
problem we've seen colony collapse
disorder we're not seeing the bee
populations that we normally have it you
can find us somebody willing to bring
hives and they become
very expensive so this was just looking
at the average fruit weight in three
different fields and this was several
well you can see it was 12 17 14
different fields grower feels that we
had when they were supplemented with
bumblebees where they were supplemented
with honeybees and where they didn't put
any bees out there and you can see
there's no differences at all in terms
of the average fruit weight per plant
okay didn't matter whether you had bees
out there or not we're still getting
that you look at this in terms of the
bee visits per flower so this is where
you've got to be sitting outside and
looking and counting the number of bees
in the type of these that are coming in
again thank God for entomologists here
and just peterson in particular but if
you look at the first graph on the left
side you know that this is where the
yellow is where we supplemented with
bumblebees and the gray is where it was
non supplemented and this is the number
of be visits didn't matter okay whether
we put these out there or not there are
enough native these they were visiting
anyway where we supplemented didn't
increase the number honeybees more
visits but again not any different
between whether it was with supplements
or not so where the what are these bees
doing out there when you when you go
through the expense and the time to put
those out there well again looking at
bees and typing the pollen that's coming
off all of them and what she found was
that pumpkins carpet pollen was one of
the last places they want to go
bumblebees and especially honey bees
would much prefer other crops you can
see corn the solon a shiva da BAC
yesterday all these others when you when
you actually looked at the pollen that
was on these this was much more
preferred to to cook urban's look her
carpets is kind of that last resort
they'll go to it but they much prefer
some of these other things so this
changes what we recommend and the grower
asked do I need to put bees in my
pumpkin fields anymore do I need to go
through that expense well based on the
work that just peterson and brian alta
been doing the answer would seem to be
no worked some with dick robinson back
in the 90s where we're looking at the
production of summer squash without
pollination okay so essential and so
again i've talked about the problem with
these but a lot of organic grower
we'll cover their plants with row covers
because they can't keep out the cucumber
beetles and the other way because if
you're covering a plant with row covers
that needs pollination and these you
don't have to take that cover off ok so
there's a lot of work that goes into
that are their plants are there squash
out there that could actually produce
fruit without pollination we found some
work again working with dick Robinson in
the 90s it seemed like there was you
know we published a paper on that that
show that especially the green the
zucchini type seem to be more likely to
do that and we did some work this past
year where we were going out we're
bagging up all the flowers going back
out and again the trend is that the
green zucchini type are going to be ones
that are able to produce without the
pollination occurring but the one that
produced one hundred percent every
single bag flower produced a marketable
fruit was this one Golden Glory which is
a yellow one so this could be very
valuable for folks that have a big
problem or are covering the plants up in
soil fertility when I came here in 1994
I've been working on the pre side dress
nitrate test is this wonderful test that
allows the grower to know the level of
my trade in that top foot of soil and if
they know that level of nitrate at the
time when the crop would typically be
side dress with additional nitrogen if
it's above 25 to 30 parts per million
they didn't need any additional nitrogen
and you know we and we were looking at
it throughout all the different crops
and it seemed like that you know be
conservative 30 parts per million if you
had a level of right before the time you
decide dress of 30 parts per million you
really didn't need any additional
nitrogen growers kind of excited about
it but not too excited it required a
separate soil test at a very busy time
of year and the results had to come back
very quickly if I went to a grower and
said Oh remember that field we tested
three weeks ago guess what you should
have put nitrogen on two weeks ago they
never were really too happy about that
and the big difference between
vegetables and field crops where this
has been working out very well for field
corn is the prices you know if I tell a
field corn grower that they might be
able to save 40 50 bucks on nitrogen
they listen if I tell a sweet corn
grower or a tomato grower pepper
rather they could save that when it
might take two thousand dollars three
thousand dollars five thousand dollars
to establish the crop they're not going
to take that chance even if I tell them
there's a ninety-five percent chance
they won't have a problem they're going
to put on that insurance application so
how do we get around that well I've
worked with query and Kettering she's
got very interesting work that she's
done using the Illinois soil nitrogen
test and if you do that with the looking
at the loss on ignition organic matter
you develop this curve and if anything
if your numbers come in with the isn t
level and the loss on ignition come in
above that you're probably not needing
any additional nitrogen out there if it
comes in below you going to have to put
that on and then working with Jeff
melkonian on the adapt end which is
really fascinating don't even need to
take a soil test for that this is just
based on computer simulations that look
at the soil that look at the environment
the past history that you've gone out
there but again it comes back to for
growers insurance applications I don't
want to take that chance on a high value
crops and I think what we're trying to
do now is figure out how do we talk
about this in terms of quality of the
crowd is having an impact on the quality
of the crop and that's where I think we
can get growers to buy into it on the
very high value crops working with Chris
smart back in 2008 we established if I
top the reform by Toffler blight is a
tremendous problem in vegetable crops it
affects more than half of the vegetables
that grow and in a very wet areas again
it just cause complete collapse of the
plant so we have a nine acre site up in
Geneva where we introduced this and
again you know one of the tough lessons
when you work with the plant pathologist
is you've got to be ready for losses and
if you look at this beautiful pumpkin
field that's down here on the right-hand
corner this was one of the best pumpkin
fields I've ever seen unfortunately it
was being grown at the phytophthora farm
and Chris smart and her graduate student
amar went out and treated it with
phytophthora made sure they added it and
it quickly melted down they get good
results but it still is a
horticulturalist sometimes bothers me I
see that sort of thing happen but again
you know this is a wonderful opportunity
because we can really study this disease
on a farm we have it fenced off we have
equipment just for that farm so we're
not going to be bringing that to other
areas Michael mizerock is he's got a
wonderful breeding program for peppers
where we're looking at resistance
varieties and we can put those up there
under some really harsh conditions we
can test some seed company material as
well under harsh conditions and your ed
miles was doing some work looking at the
possibility of using some cover cropping
between Rosa plastic to stop the
splashing that would come from the
between row area onto the plants where
again even with some of the resistant
varieties they still might succumb to
the splashing in the foliar phase of the
disease in processing vegetables there's
two major processors that we have in New
York today seneca foods who has been in
the state for many many many years and
bond well who you know you go back to a
bird's eye and we can go back to agora
Lincoln is sort of a long history but
those are the ones that I want the major
producers of those crops here in New
York and again what we do and Jim really
leads this program is the variety trial
program that we do and this is really
expanded we do sweet corn peas and beans
every year and I think what sets our
program apart from a lot of others is
that yes we do the growing in the field
we look at the horticultural
characteristics in the field but then we
can bring the product back into the food
science building into the pilot plant we
can freeze it we can can it and then
what we do in the fall we bring the
processors we'd bring the seed company
folks back where they actually will look
at the canned peas the canned corn the
the frozen product and see what does it
look like when it's processed maybe
something looked really good in the
field but if it processes kind of gray
it's not something they're going to want
to be able to use and they can pick that
up in those trials that way and again I
really have Jim to thank for leading the
effort on that getting into extension
seventy percent or it had been seventy
percent that's probably going to go down
there's a lot of sort of traditional
things I've been doing and probably some
non-traditional things as well you know
down here that there's no reason why I
can't have some fun with things back
here you look at the lower corner there
it says cornell vs rutgers and
was when I challenged my cornell peers
about who had the better tasting tomato
than the jersey tomato or New York so
they grew the same variety to different
locations and we took this down to New
Jersey where they have this 2,000 people
come in for this huge tomato fest and I
am proud to say that we killed New
Jersey in terms of the taste probably
more to do with the at the stage of
rightness of our Tomatoes compared to
anything else but I'll still say that we
we beat them and they don't like that to
be publicized too much either certainly
I work a lot this is something that I
took over was the the Cornell guidelines
used to be called the recommendations
when I arrived we had two separate books
we had a book on culture we had a book
on essentially pesticides pest control
and got a grant for petzl to my Kaufman
and I back before Mike Hoffman was the
administrator when he was still useful
and Mike's not here hopefully and we
were able to get a grant and reformat to
put everything back into one book and
the idea was we wanted to have all the
cultural information there too because
so much of that you know the pesticides
are important but they should be the
last resort we wanted to give them sort
of equal footing with some of the
cultural things that grower can do
before they need to reach for the
pesticide and we also have we're the
first guidelines and think to be up on
the web and it's not it's more than just
a PDF version that we have because
thanks again to curb petzl and now with
abby seaman you know we have this
available where there's links to
everything so if you go in and you go
into a chapter on pumpkins you can click
on something go to variety trials on
pumpkins you can go see what's been done
in terms of disease control trials that
they have just with a click so again you
know the big question is how long we're
going to be able to continue that the
other guidelines they're working through
P map are not going to be available this
year online we still have arts because
we've been really thanks to curtain and
Abby we've been doing in a different way
but we're surveying the growers now to
see just how important they feel this is
the Empire Expo I know many of you have
been speakers up there and again this is
currently it's a four-day meeting when
we include the becker form
form named after Bob Becker is focusing
on you know some major issue that's
facing the fruit the vegetable industry
at this time tends to be on labor
because that is seems to be the number
one issue we have three days of sessions
focused on educational meetings as 40
different sessions that we have lots of
exhibitors lots of it attendees and
again we've seen this this grow from the
old vegetable conference and some of you
remember and then we had the berry
growers join us we had the horse society
join us we've had direct marketers join
us the New York farm Federation farm
market Federation join us the flower
growers joining us so it's getting
bigger all the time and that you know
it's really what we love to see is that
again you know instead of trying two
separate things out let's get together
and focus on the big picture and it's
been working really well and then I want
to take some time just talk about the
Cornell regional teams because this has
a big impact I think on us here at the
University has impacted a good way and
has an impact on a bad way and this is
what I covered if any of you remember
that seminar I gave where I had 20
seconds to talk about every different
each slide that I had I didn't have much
time so the Cornell regional teams
bursts you know the traditional
extension and what's the difference and
if you look at the traditional you know
it was County County focus there was a
single County they were employed by the
county they were for the most part of
general list it wasn't too much research
salary was lower bachelor's degree
they're up for counting review and they
did work with the faculty but again we
didn't have the really the strong
relationship I think that we're getting
from the regional folks which again are
going across many counties they are
considered Cornell employees although a
good chunk of the money that supports
them does come from the county's their
specialists they have a research
component they're expected to be a
leader in that area of research a higher
salary with that a master's degree is
required and again the review that we do
on an annual basis and then for a
three-year or five-year reappointment
you know is done here at the college
working with input from growers working
from input from the county people as
well and for
input from faculty so again it's very
different the research components
expected reputation lots of grant
writing and the expectation to publish
as well and you know we have some really
successful programs out there and we
could talk a bit if I was more familiar
with some of the fruit programs I could
go on and on about them and the
ornamentals which again we don't have as
regional course we have some wonderful
people but you know judge Reed it's
really taking the state lead in terms of
high tunnels and here's Chuck forint
who's wonderful with equipment and
kristi koplin who's become a really an
international leader in onions and
crystal stewart who's doing incredible
work with garlic again these are all
specialists and has really done a good
job in doing that you know having them
out there they're going to be the first
ones that see things like Swede Minj and
cabbage and drosophila and stink bug and
lee kuan and working with the
entomologist of the pathologist's and
some of these new and emerging pests you
know perfect combination that we have
we've got this is probably outdated I
think we may have more than 10 teams now
at least 34 specialists with retirement
some new people hired it's probably
about there and what's missing we don't
have the ornamental horticulture people
involved and that's something that I
think we really got to make a change
over the next few years wonderful
educators out there that are more
county-based or an unofficial
multi-county programs that they do have
the funding where does the funding come
from for this seventy two percent
theoretically supposed to come from the
county's twenty percent from Cornell and
then eight percent was expected to be
generated by the program itself and that
could be through grants that could be
from meeting fees and things like that
in reality if you just look at this is
just a from 2011 you know the county
funds have been actually going down this
costs have gone up they haven't
increased the money that they're putting
into these programs so now we're seeing
in the Cornell vegetable program you
know down to about fifty three percent
county funding Cornell is staying the
same and then the money where it's
coming from is the incredible amount of
money that the teams are bringing in
mostly through grant writing
and that's just sort of the how the team
operates and you know the connection to
to campus the connection to the county
and the connection to the stakeholders
and you know I think there's there's
real advantages to that to that system
we have good educators of wonderful
people to work with their co-operators
on grants sometimes they're writing in
the grants higher salary it's great
we're getting better people to come in
here and you know if you when you were
offering twenty two thousand dollars for
a County Extension position people were
finding other jobs sometimes they'd come
for just a couple years of experience
and then leave so again we can get these
folks to stay and really develop
expertise in areas why did it happen now
like a couple of things that really
pushed it you know this has been talked
about for years when when I came on bob
becker had a file about this thick that
talked about all of the attempts that
had been made in his entire time here to
regionalize programs so it's been it's
been talked about for years you know the
recession I think a lot of counties
thinking beyond their borders because
well if we're sharing a specialist you
know maybe we could share the HR person
maybe we could share the finance people
and so they're starting to break out as
some of their thinking in terms of it
you know it ends at the county border
we've had such wonderful success with
the existing teams and with the
educators that we have you know
stakeholders are really buying into this
they like working with that they like
having the applied research being done
on their farms and you know another
issue we've got is people like me are
not being replaced and maybe some people
would say thank God for that but when
you when you look at that and just doing
some numbers I'm just looking at the
faculty that are working in vegetable
crops that were working in vegetable
crops from I was hired in 1994 in Geneva
and Ithaca I'm sure we can make the same
list for ornamentals we could do the
same thing for for fruit as well I've
got ten people I've got a little
asterisk by Chris wien since he's still
technically here but he's on facebook
he is on phase retirement but we but I
just asked i just used him last week for
a question we had on onions and
certainly but you know we won't have
chris around too much longer here at the
at the college and how many people were
hired that are working strictly on
vegetables that were hired in either
geneva ithaca since 1994 how many do you
think in again just horticulture now
talking animala g plant pathology give
me a number i I count two I got a new
came in 96 Phil Griffiths Griff came in
99 we could potentially put Laurie drink
water in here but I think of laura is
more of a systems person you know it's
looking at some of the big picture I
mean these are the folks that have been
hired for vegetables we've lost 10 we've
got to I do the same math for the
extension educators you know these are
the people we lost since 94 retirement
moving on to other jobs and on the right
hand side these are the people that were
hired ok our numbers are up on the
extension side where we're going to this
regional based whether we want to or not
it's happening and I think some of us
may not even be aware until you really
sit down and think about it that way
I've got Carol McNeil on in the middle
she was there when I started she's still
here and I should should have put a be
semen in there as well because it's also
somebody there but again that's really
happening here it's something that that
has an impact I think on on you know
where we're going to be and what we're
going to be doing in the future talked
about some of the challenges you know
County always looking out for themselves
what's in it for me and I think they've
gotten much better at that will the
outside funding would be enough hasn't
been a problem will compete will the
will a judge read working in chi tunnels
and getting grants and high tunnels is
that going to compete for me for the
same amount of money you know there's
there's more than enough research to go
around the other complaint or concern we
had at the time was the extension
educators and just going to go where the
money is and then I'm going to be
focused on the stakeholder questions but
you know it between the Sarah program
for viability Institute and others
there's good money
for grant funding for some of these
apply projects so again some of those
concerns haven't really come up what we
do need to think about you know these
people have very good expertise but will
they have enough of the expertise to go
beyond you know some of the field work
that they're doing very good applied
field work they're doing will they have
access to greenhouse facilities or labs
probably not you know they're going to
be able to keep up with and lead
technological innovations doing jobs
that you know 20 years ago was being
done by faculty at somewhat reduced
salaries compared to what the faculty
we're getting the absence of ornamental
horticulture we've got to do something
about getting those folks represented
and then for those of you that are just
starting out of your graduate students
here an undergraduate here one of the
biggest problems we have is finding
qualified masters students for these
positions okay it took us three searches
to add a new faculty or a new extension
educator and it will be starting May
first in western New York three searches
we made two offers they had other
positions other jobs were offers were
made and we lost and we finally did get
I think a very good person with PhD in
plant pathology but certainly in new
york and from what I'm seeing in other
places you know this type of job and
this reinvention of extension where
people have written off for so many
years you know there's jobs out there
for somebody that it was comfortable in
the field and working with growers and
then finally I just wanted to finish up
talking about some of the work I do with
in gardening and getting old gardening
we talked all about the research and you
talked about working with growers and
processing growers and 3,000 acre
growers what are you doing working in
gardening it's a small part of my job
but it's what I really like because when
you work with gardeners they are there
because they want to hear what you have
to say they're not there for the
pesticide credits I realize that's why
many growers are there so there's a lot
of enthusiasm it's the same as working
with you know teaching students that are
in classes that really want to be there
and so I and I think it's a great bridge
for the public
doesn't understand agriculture if you
can use gardening as a way to get them
to understand not only agriculture but
science okay I think that's really
important as we try to move the public
in New York we've got so a huge
percentage of people that are totally
clueless about agriculture we want them
on our side so you can use gardening I
think there's a way to talk about
agriculture and talk about science but
working with Chris smart we've been
doing a program with the Geneva
elementary schools where we've have K
through 12 but really it's more k
through third grade fourth grade and
what we do is every year we go over we
meet with the third grades this year I
think there's eight classes and 160 kids
we talked to them about seeds we talked
to them about plants they plant they
start the seeds and things that we bring
the give him the potting mix the the
trays Chris brings it back we put it in
the greenhouse we grow it there the kids
walk up from their school they visit the
experiment station they could go through
her lab they see microscopes they see
young people graduate students that are
working in science and hearing about
potential jobs that could be available
for them these are kids you know Geneva
we've got everything up there from from
very very low income to kids that are
coming out of very successful and rich
families and for some they never get
exposed to this sort of thing we take
them through the greenhouse we show them
what's going on out there and yes many
times they're more interested in the fan
that's blowing cool air in on them
because they're complaining because it's
so hot but I think still you're making
some impact and then we take everything
back and we plant everything out at this
huge garden that we have and every class
gets do that and that's followed by a
summer science camp that Chris has put
together and we're in our 10th year of
doing that where we bring in scientists
from Hobart and William Smith we bring
in scientists from the experiment
station they talk about their areas that
they're working in and they give the
kids projects that they can work on its
third graders going into 4th grade you
know and if you can get kids interested
in gardening I mean all the studies will
show that it going to be more active
they're going to think about and eat
healthier and is so important today so I
like to think that you know we are
having some impact but it is a lot of
fun as well to be working with this
group of kids
and again we do some weird things here
we're planting into straw bales and we
needed a little experiment where you put
nitrogen on it and create this little
mini compost pile and it gets really hot
and we put thermometers in and the kids
were going out and registering the
temperature of the bales where we put
ammonium nitrate inverse blood meal
where was just water so your little
experiments that they can do weird
planters that we have and you know and
finally I just want to say that I've
been very very fortunate in my life to
you know working first at Rutgers of PhD
from the ohio state university and then
going back to rutgers and working there
and still having some some good
connections with the Pope's there and
then coming here to Cornell I know
sometimes it's easy to get frustrated
with you know demands that the
administration is doing or going putting
in things into your activity in sight
reports but you know you got to take a
step back sometimes and just think well
I'm going to speak for myself I'm very
lucky I can work with somebody that's
thinking about creating an Eastern
broccoli market or creating heart-shaped
tomatoes or somebody that's willing to
get up at five o'clock in the morning to
count the number of bees visiting a
flower and what type of pollen they have
and I've gotta work with a technician
who not only will come in on the fourth
of July to help harvest peas but
motivates the summer kids we have to do
the same thing and Chris smart who's
just this wonderful person to work with
in terms of the phytophthora work in the
schools and you know I think a lot of
people don't get up and look forward to
coming to work and yeah if you can think
it's sound well on some of the negative
things that we all have to face but
we're I think pretty lucky and with that
I'm going to stop and happy to try to
answer some questions with two minutes
left
you
so the question was how do we get the
new extension director we'd give him a
roadmap to get the ornamental people
there you know I think I think the
template is there we know how to do it
we've got this now eastern New York
horticulture team so now we've got fruit
and vegetables there we can add those
others to it chris is on board one of
the things I didn't mention one of the
reasons why this has been happening with
the regional teams is because we've had
Helene Dillard Chris Watkins especially
mark Giles that really helped push this
forward so I think it's there I think
we've got the people in place I think
it's just a matter of taking the next
step right so the question was about the
the PS NT the precise dose nitrate test
and what that does is it takes a
snapshot of the available nitrate that's
in that top foot of soil and what goes
into that night raid level is of course
the the organic matter that's being
broken down and freeing up some of that
available nitrogen so all the additional
nitrogen fertilizer that might have been
put in there in the spring or the year
before that might still be in the soil
so all that goes into that p sm t value
and then from that value we could tell a
grower you don't need to add any
additional nitrogen or yes you do need
to add additional nitrogen yeah so the
question is you know what could be
available in the soil nitrogen that
could be available if the general rule
of thumb that we have is based on a soil
test if you've got for every one percent
organic matter that you've got in your
soil you can assume you probably have 15
to 20 pounds of available nitrogen so a
three percent organic matter the level
in the soil is going to give you
potentially 45 to 60 pounds of available
nitrogen that they don't need to add to
that that would be available and that
gets into a problem and
I want to get into a couple of years
hopefully if Brian Wolfe we've been
talking about that I know Chris Wayne
has looked into this too much nitrogen
in pumpkins for example has really very
bad effects in terms of the yield hasn't
effect on the female flowers either it
directly or through pollination or
through too much shading so you can have
this beautiful field of pumpkins that
look great and then when the foliage
dies back at the end of the year there's
no pumpkins out there and that nitrogen
is playing a role in that somehow yeah
and I'm just repeating the question for
the folks in Geneva is about urban
horticulture and that you know it's not
an area that we've really got people
working too much in here in this
department or even so much an extension
but Marvin and I just had a chance to
sit down with with griff last week and
he is really you know you want to talk
to somebody that's got an idea of where
we're going in urban horticulture in
terms of growing food and warehouses and
lighting and stuff and there's a whole
area that maybe for some people and they
think of urban horticulture the thinking
of gardening and large gardens and
rooftop gardens and that's part of the
mix but there's a whole different thing
that we can add to it as well and I know
as a department we've been talking about
you know a position in that and I think
there's a lot of different ways we could
go with that but there certainly could
be some a real growth area in that and
the food deserts that are in cities you
know can we provide that grow the food
ourselves well what should happen is
they have to pay more they have to pay
lots more I showed you that the picture
of the industry the fresh market side is
worth 450 million and if I go very
broadly in terms of what they're raising
between onions potatoes cabbage you know
they're probably not over even a hundred
thousand dollars processing which is
worth one tenth of that is raising one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars it we
have just it's a drop in the bucket in
terms of the support we're currently
getting we really need to to increase
that you know five to ten fold at least
and that's got to happen or there aren't
going to be the people they're not going
to be the faculty and it's not going to
be the research that does at the end
she has to step up and I think they're
getting there but it's it's where we
have to go so the question was about
other things you could plan to help
bring in the pollinators the problem is
it's very attractive to the pollinators
and the mason bees that's where they're
going to go and we'll see the same thing
they'll just be covered in that pollen
it seems like they're there's no
probably the best thing you can do is
create a habitat sort of a wild area
close to the field that isn't plowed
where a lot of the native bees will make
their nest okay and that really helps
quite a bit but you know it's big change
so the well you all heard the question
was is there an optimum ratio male to
female flowers for pumpkin production it
changes so much through the season keen
on that you know depending on whether
it's very hot in the stressor it's very
cold and it's very rainy and I've seen
very productive good production out of
all those systems that the key is as
long as there's that a female flower
that a be confined and the male flower
is well usually not a problem with the
male flowers so as long as you've got
some some female flowers there you
should be okay is there an ideal ratio I
don't know Michael here was work or okay
because he does some work in curve it's
and but there probably is it's just
something I wouldn't be aware of yeah so
the question was about using epiphone
for sex expression and no it's it's not
a labeled material i played around with
it a bit and it does work but it seems
like you get enough female flowers that
you'll be okay well anything else from
Geneva all right oh good thank you very
much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu